I'm going to teach you and the body
format is tons of them okay here it is
okay so looks like so right at least I
hope it is so under algebra particularly
under this topic called price and
factors if you have not already you're
soon going to learn this particular
result shape oh it's cold
there's sum and difference of cubes and
you see the sum and difference of cubes
it's a result now what it means it's not
that important
okay it's called the sum and difference
of cubes the point though is that this
is fiendishly hard to remember even
people all the way up to these bars
right get confused about this and the
the fruit of that is that you know if
you ask someone in like first uni if
they're not doing maths and uni
none of them will remember this because
they've held it in their brain just long
enough to use it for their HSC and then
off it goes okay it's hard to remember
now yeah well okay let me show you right
now it's tricky because you all these
numbers and letters but Artois what's
the hardest thing to remember it's not
the numbers and then string a lot okay
as a math teacher
I see people get these wrong all the
time I'll tell you exactly what they get
wrong it's these guys it's the plus or
minus
it's the signs now cuz any can even tell
me why do you think that would be the
thing that's hard to remember about
these formulas no it's change the whole
equation okay number one like if I
change what is to applause that's a -
it's totally breaks down it's not the
same thing at all anymore
okay you know what else tell me any
other reasons what that might be the
particular thing that's tricky yeah so
our brains are actually quite good at
like even seeing kind of the the broad
picture of what it looks like okay X's
and Y's and this particular in here
looks kind of like a perfect square
anyway right
the reason the plus or minus is a hard
to remember is because there's number
one there's three of them right and
there's all different kinds of ways to
combine pluses and minuses right it's
like is it plus minus plus whereas plus
minus minus or minus plus plus or it's
all different ways together and they're
very similar to each other do you see
how close they are but no quiet right
they're just close enough to confuse you
right so still try and remember that you
remember this this is how I remember
them okay
so you write down sir what a soap stand
for I'll tell you so stands for same
opposite always positive okay now I will
show you what it means okay there are
three signs there pluses or minuses
right you have to the hot guys working
out which ones which okay all we have to
do is think about how you start let's do
this bottom one okay so it starts with
the clients so the three sides I'm going
to get are in order first the same all
right that's a virus it's the same as
the one I had on foot the next one's
gonna be opposite it's a plus and this
last one I don't know if it's a plus no
matter which one you've got it it's
always bothered okay you tell me which
is easier to remember all of this Java
gr or that now much to my frustration I
learnt this when I was training to
become a math teacher so when I was like
second or third DVD I was like why did
no one tell me is five years ago but it
would have been useful to me instead I
worked my brain trying to
is and everybody got something question
through all okay but now you guys know
it so you can use it in this comes more
like in question try once you tell me go
drastically money on you
I can tell you about fair which is about
sketching graphs you can ask whether it
stands for later on if you want there's
one called tape which is about a three
unit mask topic called mathematical
induction the point is there are lots of
them and you can make ones up if there
isn't one you've got a series of steps
like four or five things it's really
hard to remember four or five things so
using the money tell me